this one is for the medicare eligible
annual enrollment period officially
starts today and your insurance agency
the sponsors of this next segment are
here to help here's how
[Music]
hello chris caruthers here again with
your insurance agency it's that time of
year to get to discuss medicare open
enrollment
thus for those who are eligible for
medicare there are many plan changes
coming this year and i want you to make
sure you sit down with your broker to
make sure you have the right plan for
you
for example we have plans that have been
around for a while and we have new plans
with even that same carrier and they're
better than the old ones and so you need
to personally move that to the new plan
today i have a special guest her name is
jody phelps and she's with aetna thank
you for being here glad to join you
medicare eligibles think that once they
enroll in a plan that that's it but
there are some changes that can happen
year over year that has some impact on
them
in healthcare technology continues to
improve in advance and during the
pandemic telehealth became very popular
to provide the health care that members
need
to get when they need it providing your
members a safer environment
i agree many of the people that i know
have really benefited from the virtual
office visits they're getting more
comfortable not having to drive across
town as well
but just want you to be aware of that
aetna has been working really hard to
grow your provider network and so that's
one of the things you need to consider
as you're looking into your benefits do
i have the right doctor do i trust my
doctor
and what other ones are available to me
now because they've been they've moved
those many doctors moved plans from year
to year we do have specific plan changes
that have been happening for this new
plan year for example we have plans for
the what we call d snips which stands
for dual eligible medicare beneficiaries
those who have medicare and medicaid we
also have many extra benefits that have
come out this year enhancements for to
meals to enhancements to
transportation to dental vision etc
but most importantly
there's the new birthday rule
for those who have medicare supplements
there's been plan changes and we have a
special enrollment period for you if you
have a medicare supplement plan so
please give us a call now chris you're
with the agency and i'm with a care
insurance carrier and during aap
medicare eligible should really be
reaching out to their local brokers i
agree
one of the issues consumers do is they
try to self enroll
and that is a big mistake you really
need to sit down with a local broker
who's going to help you determine
which plan is best for you help you find
your doctors make sure your medications
are covered and there and those also
will be there for you a time of need so
if you're wondering how to reach us
there's several ways we do have in-home
appointments for you
you can do it by virtually by the
telephone we do have the technology to
help enroll you that way but also we
have retail locations throughout the
valley not just our locations at the
malls in our corporate office but we
have also retail locations
that we've even partnered with with
aetna and some of the supermarkets
you can find a local broker at one of
the local grocery stores on blue diamond
and decatur and rainbow and charleston
thank you your insurance agency for
sponsoring this segment remember annual
enrollment period is october 15th
through december 7th so for more
information you can call their meadows
mall location at
702-52425 excuse me five five zero zero
or visit y i a n b dot com slash
locations to find the one nearest you
las vegas now we'll be right back